Thomas Gibson is officially dismissed
from Criminal Minds
I'm on the job drop your weapon on Aaron
Hotchner with the FBI the actor who is
an original cast member on the crime
drama has been fired from the CBS series
following an on-set altercation where he
allegedly kicked a writer he was
temporarily suspended in a statement
released to ET the show explained their
decision quote Thomas Gibson has been
dismissed from Criminal Minds creative
details for how the characters exit will
be addressed in the show will be
announced at a later date
Gibson thank the cast and crew in a
statement and added I love Criminal
Minds and have put my heart and soul
into it for the last 12 years I had
hoped to see it through to the end but
that won't be possible now et chatted
with the actor during a set visit last
month he seemed excited about the
upcoming season I know you don't do the
writing but does it ever blow your mind
like when you look at the scripts how
they still keep it fresh and new and
interesting totally I'm gonna direct two
episodes from now and I just got my
script over the weekend and it's
fantastic it's a really great episode
that I'm really looking forward to
you